[Music]
what is going on there reject nation i
always do this who is what is going on
hello what is going on there reject
nation greg here today so we got a very
very big announcement to make we
actually wanted to make this
announcement last week last week john
actually caught the vid diesel and then
i thought i was fine but then a few days
later i ended up testing positive so at
this moment still got the vid diesel but
i feel good so i told the team that's
right team there's a you'll hear more on
that in just a second i said team we are
making the announcement because i feel
good right now and i want to let the
people know so for the longest time
we've been asked if we're ever going to
do this and now since thanks to you the
reject nation we have gotten to a
million subscribers we thought it was
about damn time something to really help
celebrate honor being a citizen of the
reject oh my god citizen of the reject
nation why have i never thought about
that i've always been saying subscribe
to get accepted to the reject nation but
what about subscribe and become a
citizen of the reject nation i think i
finally figured i think that's the one
we got to go in from here on out anyway
citizens of the reject nation i always
said that if we ever did do this that
would have to be something really cool
really special really creative and
really collaborative as well and i know
i can resort to making like stupid
sarcastic comments from time to time uh
but i just want to take a moment to say
that even though it's just like at the
first day of launch i am already very
proud of everything we have already
accomplished with this i really think
that what we have on our hands here
right now is something very special and
at first you might be like
is that it but trust me it's gonna be a
little different than when your average
youtuber announces this that's right i'm
comparing myself we're finally gonna
have some goddamn merch there goes
greg's hands again we have officially
partnered up with this this super nerdy
store bunch of nerds of a super nerdy
store and we've been approached by
people in the past being like hey you
know we must start creating some apparel
beanies whatever we can help you with
that for a variety of reasons we've
always said no never really felt like
the right time for some reason or that
we didn't like the feeling of the
clothes we had one for such a brief
moment but we were kind of testing out
but we ultimately didn't like the way
the designs were actually going and we
didn't like the clothes so we just got
to try to not let people ever really
know about it but more important than
anything else for whoever really knows
me knows that more than what i'm doing i
care more about who i'm working with so
this product launch is not just that of
the real rejects but
with a
couple of hacks you might have heard of
heavy spoilers and screen crush i picked
up that paul from heavy spoilers and
ryan arie from screen crusher friends of
mine don't embarrass yourself shut the
[ __ ] up ryanairy
and then i say best friends but they
they don't ever say it back to me but i
know they know they're just putting up a
sarcastic wall
the other day they call me the mclovin
of the group and everyone knows
mclovin's the leader all of us have had
ideas and want to create products and
have a shop to represent our brand our
brand they're always still selling
software our brand because we're
influencers and we're influencing you to
go to our shop but the main thing that
we end up talking about when it comes to
launching a line like this is just how
much of an undertaking it can be and it
truly just excited us at the thought of
us doing it together i know that sounds
a little bit i need to just
be sincere so and one of the ways we've
been saying it is we've partnered up so
we can create one place where you can
express your inner nerd and get the kind
of products that help you stand out from
the crowd we joke like we're the
avengers coming together on this you
know paul is like iron man and ryan is
like captain america
they say i'm like wholesome but i like
to think i'm the thor of the group now
listen i don't think it'd be wise
legally for me to put down some other
companies that also produce nerdy gear
but these are better these are the more
if you know you know kind of shirts you
won't get called fake nerd if you rock
this [ __ ] so this place is called zero
edition so we've been working on these
for months got way more coming been
going over designs testing them out
everything everything is very high
quality they're things we would actually
wear got a whole shipment coming this
week or something wearing them online
actually this jacket that i'm wearing
right now uh was one of the test jackets
and there's like the three others over
there with different fabrics and i said
no forget that crap this one this is
this is the fabric the softness this is
the jacket the reject nation's gonna be
wearing the shirts are soft but they'll
make you look good you'll get
compliments you'll feel validated
they'll ask where did you get that shirt
and you'll tell them you'll tell them
that you favor our shirts over heavy
spoilers and screen crush you know even
though it's not a competition but i'm
gonna make it one they're gonna
accentuate the shoulders arms upper
chest gonna be nice to you around the
midsection and as someone who's like
always bloated i tend to be
self-conscious about that why don't i
just zip this up right now while we're
at it the designs have been
collaborations between us and a team of
designers who have all told me that they
personally elect me more than paul and
ryan but that's not the main point here
they're all a bunch of nerds too like
they they're so nerdy way more nerdy
than i could have ever imagined i steal
their lunch box and
shove chocolate milk on their nose river
bullies did i don't know but whenever we
pitch designs to them they have that if
you know you know kind of mentality and
they always see the vision fully through
like it is so cool to see things come to
life and look better than how i pencil
drew them so yeah they're they're
amazing so we have some great options
for you to rock to show your love for
the channel this one i spend way too
much time trying to narrow down to the
one i perfectly like but the other ones
are the ones i'm actually very very very
excited about the regular drops we're
going to be doing the limited the
limited run ones a one of a kind prints
is a terminology i heard recently for
the first time i'm like i like that i'm
gonna remember that so when they run out
they run out so with us i was thinking
about like with the reject nation have
some of the biggest things we've covered
in the last couple years and sometimes
you watch so many things they just start
to mash together you have an idea where
i'm going with this so our first sick
mashup shirt is vecna from stranger
things
rocking this is spoilers here by the
spoiler report vecna from netflix's
stranger things rocking the zero zero
one jacket from squid game i know a lot
of us when we saw that you can't trust
the number one and then bam was like
we love covering both those shows here
so yeah we made a shirt for you guys
there's more designs there and there's
other mashups coming in other designs
but yeah i wanted to that was the one i
was like oh my god i can't wait to wear
that once it's got to be the first one
i won this right now is absolutely the
best way to support the channel and what
we do here it took us a long time to
find the right way to proceed
confidently this is the way this is the
way so thank you all for being here but
also reject nation it's a democracy we
not only want you to celebrate and
identify as a member of this community
but also we value your input here the
reject nation so we'd love to hear your
feedback anything good i'll take credit
for anything bad i'll blame someone else
and we'd love to hear your pitches on
more mashup shirt ideas we're open to
suggestions people gotta thank screen
crush and heavy spoilers without them
this would not have been possible
sincerely i'm giving you guys a sincere
one we want to thank you the viewers for
supporting us i am beyond thrilled to
show you guys what we have at shopzero
edition.com also if you end up buying
something please tweet your purchases so
we can show that we are a worthy
addition to the zero edition and plain
and simple we're just excited to see
what the future holds for for zero
edition i want to do a panel one day of
us just talking about this not all the
years of youtubing it's just about zero
edition thanks again and i'll in this
sincerely by saying i'm just honored to
be a part of this team um
it's it really is something special you
know i just wanted to make this
announcement a little bit fun but that's
kind of like the vibe that we have when
we're all just talking even when we're
talking about things that we should be
taking seriously so it's it's just a
really fun place to be a part of so yeah
as much as we have our ideas you know we
also really want to hear what you guys
have to say because a lot of the
inspiration tends to come from what's
being uh generated or being talked about
our way as well thank you guys so much
for this and i'm i'm i really am excited
like the the more than just heavy
spoilers and screen crush like the whole
rest of the team are everyone is just so
cool to talk to it's such a blast to
talk with everyone it's so much fun
constantly
i wish they would include me more
this tends to be the kind of stupid vibe
that we have going on thank you again
and i'll talk with you all soon
[Music]